so in saving the galaxy again Ralph is
gonna do it
[Music]
Oh
and almost hit
you
hey youtubers it's Charlie we got some
new guardians of the galaxy music new
baby crew and some new infinity war
crossover details let's break it down
this is so great I love the fact that
baby Groot is literally plugging in an
amp on this platform as they're getting
ready to fight this giant monster so
we're going to save the galaxy again the
title of a teaser is just you're welcome
that's all it says it's so funny Alexa
really on the way knows they're
marketing this film and also using music
at the same time there's actually a new
round of the Spider Man giveaway too but
I'll talk about that at the end of this
the songs that everyone's asking about
in this is actually David Bowie's
suffragette City you could take a couple
of different meanings for the very
specific use of this song because when
James Gunn put songs and guardians of
the galaxy they usually have special
meaning so this song in particular might
have to do with the idea of him
liberating all the other members of the
guardians of the galaxy in the demands
of the relationship just completely
overwhelming all the characters there
were a bunch of journalists that got to
visit the actors on set ask them
questions and they did say when
guardians picks up they've been
travelling together in that ship for so
long that they definitely can't stand
each other even though they're a kind of
dysfunctional family so they work very
well together but if you've ever grown
up with the sibling you had to share a
room it gets a little crazy after a
while let me know in the comments though
what do you think the deal is with him
plugging in this amp while they're
getting ready to fight the monster it
doesn't seem like they're just going to
jam out to awesome mix vol 2 while
they're fighting this creature maybe it
has something to do with the sonic waves
of the songs there's something very
specific this is kind of like a Bowie
teaser the sort of sad Bowie detail from
behind the scenes is it James Gunn
before he passed away had intended to
offer him a part in the movie so you can
imagine Bowie as Adam warlock or some
cosmic figure but he was going to be
somewhere in there before he passed away
but on a slightly happier note because
of all the infinity war Marvel craziness
has been dropping in the past couple of
days James Gunn's been talking about his
involvement with that movie even more so
he's mostly working with the Russos on
the Guardian stuff they're doing when
they were standing on that set in the
teaser that day one moment it actually
looked like a set from sanctuary set in
outer space
which is a guardians of the galaxy set
its tanis's home base
we only saw him in a chair there but he
has a spaceship there are other people
there it's not just him and a bunch of
rocks floating around but all these
characters all these different movies
coming together makes a little more
sense when you hear the pitch they talk
about vignette 'add storytelling so
there'll be a lot of guardians of the
galaxy scenes
separate from a lot of the earth-based
Avenger scenes and then you'll have some
crossover in maybe a few moments where
everybody's on-screen together but for
the most part it's not going to be
everybody walking around at the same
time through every scene you're going to
jump to the cosmic characters you'll
just to the earth-based characters
you'll jump to people like dr. strange
that are running around trying to help
people they'll probably be some
dimension crossing you'll have the
Asgardian characters so that just
scratches the surface you have to
consider Black Panthers the ant-man
characters so that's why you have all
these other directors who are serving as
producers on this film that kind of
happened on Civil War the ant-man
director says he's very protective of
those characters so whenever they were
doing things with the ant-man character
he would give them those just to make
sure that it was in keeping with the
tone of the character from his movie so
whatever you did see him show up in the
movie he wouldn't be wildly different
from the ant-man that you saw last year
but because infinity war is so much of a
bigger story in there are so many more
characters the work that each of the
other directors do as producers with
their own characters is so much more
important that's one of the biggest
things people are worried about with
infinity war too many characters it's
going to fall apart so that's why you
bring in these other Marvel directors to
make sure that their characters stay
their characters and you don't wind up
with a situation where everybody starts
acting like Tony Stark getting really
sardonic and quippy although they did
say that Tony Stark has matured a lot by
Avengers infinity war we'll see what
that actually looks like because Robert
Downey juniors process onset is very
different from the other actors he
definitely owns the set but Tom Halle
did say that he sort of took him under
his wing during Civil War and helped him
out because he was a new kid on set so
the funny thing about that is that a lot
of the other actors were really jealous
of spider-man just because he got to
spend so much time with Robert Downey
jr. and if you've ever heard stories
about Robert Downey
you're on those film sets he's almost
like a king that gets moved around with
this giant troupe of support people so
he has like this giant base camp that's
separate from all the other actors you
can definitely tell he's one of the most
important people behind the scenes at
Marvel which is also why he's one of the
highest-paid but it's funny to listen to
people like Anthony Mackie talk about
the time he got invited to Roberts base
camp so the whole difference with the
guardians when we get to Avengers
infinity war is that the Avengers have
been broken up the guardians are
stronger than ever and they know what's
been going on in the galaxy way more
than Iron Man does now he's had visions
that Scarlet Witch has given him but
they've actually seen things they've
seen Ronan they've seen the power Geoff
Peter quill has even used the power gem
so even though he might not fully
understand it he knows who the collector
is he has the support of the Nova Corps
and he has Gamora and nebula who know
about what's going on with Bannos they
have all the information that the
Avengers need so here's my other big
question at what point during infinity
war do you think that Chris Pratt will
actually be on screen with Robert Downey
jr. do you think it's actually going to
happen on this set or do you think that
it's going to happen much later in the
film the thing about getting the
Avengers back together and healing the
wound between Captain America and Iron
Man and they said that that would be a
very important thing during infinity war
is it something crazy has to happen
first so my guess is a Spanos does
something crazy to bring them all
together maybe he takes the mind stone
from visions 4head crippling him or
killing him outright in that catalyzes
the old team
look our buddy is dead this giant threat
is here we need to come together so
something major like that is going to
have to happen before civil war is water
under the bridge because Robert Downey
jr. did say in his QA that Steve Rogers
is still on his list
so we'll see so what's going to happen
tonight is Walking Dead is back I'll be
posting a new episode video after it
airs that will be late there's new Game
of Thrones and new Doctor Strange so
I'll post that on Monday so leave all
your requests for guardians of the
galaxy bonus videos in the comments
below and I'll say congratulations to
Leon Bali you're the latest spider-man
giveaway winner you win one of those
Hasbro action figures so there's a new
round
it starts in this video all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on this video I'll announce
the winner when I post that Doctor
Strange video while you wait so that you
can click here for all my Lego Batman
Easter eggs there's a crazy number of
them and you can click here for all the
Infinity Ward madness in the last couple
days thank you so much for watching
everyone plus I thought I'll see you in
the next video